SHARANGOVIVI HAMILTON AND REBOU
AND THEY SCORE!
JACK HUGHES!
JERSEY.
YOU SEE JACK HUGHES FIND THAT O.
ANOTHER PENALTY IS COMING UP!
IT'S AGAINST THE
THAT OCOC ON A TEE.
THERE IS TRAFFIC INGH
SPOTS OR RUTS YOU'RE IN AS A
TEAM.
RETTY
VEGAS KNIGHTS TAKE 2-1 LEAD.
KOLSAR.
I DON'T KNOW IF CARRIER
REDIRECTED THAT PUCK OR HIT THE
HERE IS JONAS SIEGENTHALER,
FIRST NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE
GOAL BY HUGHES.
SAVE,  FOR
SMITH.
UNDER PRESSURE BY   WAY.
BEHIND THE NET.
PUCK TAKEN BY SEVERSON FORICE
LOOK
TOP PL A 3-1 GAME.
>> Ken: THAT ONE HURTS.E THAT I
WHO MAKES THAT PASS.
IT'S RIGHT ON THE TAPE.
LOOK AT THI
WITH VEGASAS HNSSON.
HERE IS BRATT.
WORKS IT IN DEEP.
JOHNSSON WINDS TO THEE LOOSE PU.
GIVES TO SEVERSON.
WORKS IT ACROSS TO TATAR AND
SHOOT AND SCORE! HESITATION.
YOU SEE TATAR PULL HIMSELF RIGHT
OUT ON THE HIGH SLOT RISER OFF
THAT MISSED THE NET.
A CHANCE FOR VESEY WALK IN THIR
PERIODS ALL SEASON LONG.
SHOT FROM SIEGENTHALER.
A BUTTERFLY OFF THE BODY HERE B.
TEAMS WITH THE NET EMPTY!
BY NICOLAS HAGUE, A HUGE BLOCK
HAMILTON ACROSS.
SEVERSON.
HUGHES!
SHOOTS!PEN NET.
TATAR IN FRONT.
WATCH THAT NO LOOK.
FAKE SSEE.
IT'S NOT A POSSIBLE.
YOU TRY TO
QUICK O